For years, fans have been enjoying Pawn Stars,
the reality show about the Harrison family
and their famed Gold and Silver Pawn Shop
in Las Vegas.
But this isn't even the family's first taste
of TV stardom, as they were previously featured
on both Comedy Central and PBS.
And before that, the cast members each had
long and interesting lives and careers outside
of television.
Surprised?
Here's a look at the Pawn Stars before all
the fame.
The Old Man
Richard Benjamin Harrison, better known as
"the Old Man," was born on March 4, 1941 in
Danville, Virginia, to what his son Rick described
in his 2011 memoir License to Pawn as "dirt
poor white trash, left to survive on their
wits."
He helped the family make ends meet by driving
a school bus at the age of 14...which had
to be pretty surreal for the other kids on
the bus.
In 1960, Richard's life changed drastically.
Just before his marriage to a girl named Joanne
Rhue, who he met at a barn dance, Richard
was arrested for stealing a car.
Instead of serving jail time, he chose to
join the Navy.
He served for 20 years, eventually moving
the family to the naval hub of San Diego,
where he and his wife took up real estate.
But when the housing market collapsed in the
early '80s, he decided to switch careers,
moving his family to Las Vegas to focus on
buying and selling gold.
And the rest, as they say, is history.
Rick Harrison
The charismatic face of Pawn Stars, Rick Harrison's
early life was a struggle.
Diagnosed with epilepsy at age eight, Rick
was confined to his bed for treatment, and
found his escape in reading — and eventually
in drugs, which began with a joint in fourth
grade.
By the time the family moved to Las Vegas,
Rick had become a slick wheeler dealer, selling
fake Gucci bags to pay the bills.
He quit that gig to help The Old Man open
a pawn shop, but there was one problem: local
laws banned pawn shops inside the city limits
until the city's population hit a quarter
of a million people.
That delayed the dream, but didn't end it,
and in 1988 the Gold and Silver Pawn Shop
opened its doors with an initial investment
of just $10,000.
Big Hoss
Born to Rick on April 27, 1983, when Rick
was just 18, Corey's childhood took place
almost entirely inside the Gold and Silver
Pawn Shop.
He started working at the shop at the age
of nine, eventually turning that entry level
position at the store polishing jewelry into
a managerial position with a five percent
cut and the promise of taking over the family
business once Rick and The Old Man retire.
In 2011, The Big Hoss got a lot smaller, shedding
close to 200 pounds thanks to gastric lap-band
surgery and dietary changes designed to help
stave off the possibility of diabetes.
Good job, Big Hoss!
Chumlee
The goofy "honorary member" of the family
who always seems a step away from getting
fired, Austin "Chumlee" Russell was born on
September 8, 1982.
His nickname of "Chumlee" came from the cartoon
Tennessee Tuxedo, "Chumley" being the walrus
sidekick of the titular penguin lead.
"Now Chumley, will you please toss up the
Sports section?"
"I'll bring it myself!"
A childhood friend of Corey's, Chumlee joined
the staff of the Gold and Silver when he was
21, and has been a constant presence at the
shop ever since, including at the Harrison's
Christmas dinner.
The Harrisons love to make light of their
friend and his semi-frequent lapses in judgment.
"Why don't they just make Cuban cigars in
America?"
"Chumlee that's probably one of the dumbest
things you ever said."
Despite that — or perhaps because of it
— he's widely considered the most popular
member of the group, with the shop's own profile
page claiming girls get nervous around him
"like perhaps One Direction or the Biebs has
just walked into the room."
Take that with a grain of salt, of course.
But there's no denying that Chum is an aid
to the Harrisons, especially with his knowledge
of games, pinball machines, and sneakers.
By God, that man loves his sneakers.
"This is a lot of my collection.
But it's not really it, this isn't everything."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this other cool stuff we
know you'll love, too!